[Music]
this yoga guru's comments
on modern medicine have outraged indians
on
and offline
[Music]
hello
has quite a following on social media
but it's not the first time people are
shaking their heads at his remarks
ramdev has a reputation for making
controversial unscientific remarks
earlier he had mocked covet patients
looking for oxygen cylinders
and his most recent comments have now
caused a huge outcry
especially from the medical community
which is still battling
a ferocious second wave of infections
the yogi withdrew his comments after
criticism by india's health minister
and the indian medical association is
urging prime minister modi to
stop the misinformation campaign on
vaccination by mr ramdev
the yoga guru has also advertised a
supposed covet 19
cure among a whole range of other
ayurvedic products
marketing coronal as a covid19 remedy
had to stop
last year when the government said there
is no data to prove it works
but recently the state of haryana
announced they distribute the product
for free to covet patients
doctors are speaking out against this
move saying this sends the wrong message
about how to treat covet 19. this is
especially dangerous
at a time when the disease is spreading
fast in rural areas
where there are extremely limited
healthcare facilities and misinformation
and myths abound in rural areas many are
hesitant to get vaccinated
for fear of negative side effects
for people staying in this
25 villages the vaccination center or
camp which was put on for these one lakh
people
no single person came from this one lakh
and took the vaccination
hesitancy is only one factor hampering
vaccination efforts
medical facilities providing vaccines
are often scarce with the closest
hospitals hours away
and only about half of india's
population has internet access
making vaccination appointments hard to
come by for many
rural areas are severely lagging behind
the big cities
lack of personnel and infrastructure is
hampering the efforts to distribute
vaccines to more remote areas
but there's an even bigger problem a
major shortage of vaccine doses
nationwide
only around three percent of nearly 1.4
billion people have been fully
vaccinated
to increase the number of doses
available domestically the government
has cancelled international exports
and has ramped up funding for local
vaccine production
but many say more needs to be done
scientists have already warned the
government that a third wave is
inevitable
they say now is the time to prepare by
working on awareness
boosting healthcare infrastructure and
increasing vaccine supplies
nobody wants to see a repeat of the
situation the country faced when the
second wave began